Now week 0 and
week 20 are both pretty interesting in
terms of the graph of this equation.
Let's take a look at what's going on.
So, we have this equation which relates
the number of weeks to the money owed,
x to y.
And we know that at 0 weeks,
or x =0, y = 200.
He owes $200.
And when x = 20, y = 0.
So after 20 weeks he
doesn't owe any money.
And I can represent
these as ordered pairs.
In this case, (0, 200).
And in this case (20, 0).
And if this is my graph paper,
I'm going to make each of these lines
represent let's say five on the x-axis.
So 5, 10, 15, 20.
And each of the lines
represent 50 on the y-axis.
So, 50, 100, 150, 200.
Well, then I can plot these points.
(0, 200), (20, 0).
And we see that they're special points.
This point, (0, 200), is special
because it's right on the y-axis.
And so, we call it the y-intercept.
It's going to be where the graph
intercepts the y-axis.
And this point, well,
it lives right on the x-axis.
So, you might be able to guess.
This is what we call the x-intercept.
And what's really cool is that these
two points fully describe a line.
They represent all the information
I need to know to draw a graph.
Because all I have to
do is connect the dots.
And generally, I want to extend my line
to continue in either direction as well.
And I almost forgot to label my axes.
Now, why don't we practice with
a slightly different graph?
Can you tell me what the x and
y-intercepts are for this graph?
Enter the x and y coordinates of
the x-intercept, and likewise for
the y-intercept.